[Music]
sean
oh hi i didn't see you there my name is
avita i hope you're well now if you're
wondering what we're doing here in the
streets of orchard road let me tell you
a little secret
marvel's shanti and the legend of the 10
rings is premiering really soon the 2nd
september so what we're doing today is
we're going to ask folks questions about
the marvel movie and the avengers in
general if they answer most questions
right they get a little goodie now let's
see how it goes
what do you know about this movie so far
i just know it's the uh the first asian
uh superhero that's out uh from marvel
studios so yeah i'm really looking
forward to it can you help me pronounce
this so that's uh
do you know who he is yeah it's uh
that's tony right he plays the mandarin
see a good guy or a bad guy um well i
mean i've read some of some of the
reviews and they said
could you show me a superhero pose dudes
are a really cool one
[Music]
okay so have you heard of marvel's
latest movie uh yes i did see some
trailers on it see whether you can
pronounce the latest hero's name
do you know this fella looks familiar
he looks like donnie yen
can you show me a superhero pose
[Music]
can you tell me who this handsome fella
is my daddy my daddy my daddy
[Music]
[Laughter]
this guy is tony long
[Music]
if you follow shaney marvel movies i
think you might recognize him oh yeah
oh right
[Music]
can you show me a superhero pose
oh yes
can you pronounce this uh
i think it's
can you show me a superhero pose maybe
you can show me the waterfall
oh there we go
are you good with your mandarin i'm
quite good
to tell me who he is and which marvel
movie he was previously in
he was what in venice he was the guy
with the
the time traveler the guy can you name
me the avengers iron man captain america
pop hawkeye doctor strange black window
black window that's a great
no this is the last thing i need y'all
to show me a superhero pose
can you pronounce this
can you show me a superhero pose
forever
you heard of the latest marvel movie
that's coming out
are you excited for it yes did you try
pronouncing his name
thank you that was a good attempt
can you name me the avengers oh um black
widow captain america iron man thor hulk
vision
do you want to show me a superhero pose
if you're a superhero
[Music]
no those were some really good superhero
poses i've got a few favorites i'm sure
you do too make sure to catch shangti in
the legend of the ten rings when it
comes out in cinemas this second
september now if you enjoyed the video
as much as i did at least hit the
subscribe button and leave a comment or
two below my name is avida thank you so
much for watching signing off
[Music]
[Applause]